Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Buried now
We're beginning chapter five and we're almost done with this again to Recap Chapter [4] was nuts
It was basically running from start to finish, but now we're gonna figure out exactly what the consequences of my actions are
[my] all of this stuff is here
[we're] now inside a large reinforce [chamber] of Sorts almost like the inside of a submarine
Us is the door shut tight far away from us along the back wall are all sorts of controls and monitors
Can clear this metal door is impenetrable?
At least to them, [I'm] fairly sure that they aren't getting in Dennis looks like a walking corpse
And I do everything in my power to not let this show in my expression
His face is a grimace shouts at me to hell with you
What were you thinking blood pools on the floor below wherever he hold his arm? I say nothing
It's all too much my brain feels like jelly
We need to get him help or he's going to bleed to death
Amy says were interrupted by men voice booming behind us just what in the hell? Do you think you're doing the man roars?
He's an older man who seems to exhume power and authority but he also looks tired and scared
[I] assume this barksdale he walks over to us from the back recesses of the chamber
We didn't have a choice same response. We had to did you override the locks on the hangar door. Yes?
I did what we had to do you have any idea what you could have done. Amy doesn't answer right away
She's furious, but she was also scared and visibly quiet and exhausted
[I'm] Gonna ask you this is who is this?
Address my question to amy preferring to get my info from her rather than whoever this is the man doesn't break eye contact with Amy
Colonel Barksdale he runs the place. She says annoyed look Barksdale
She says you can berate me and lecture me all you want when this message over, but right now
I have a wounded civilian here and as you can see several entities trying to get into this room
So if you can actually do something instead of sitting on your throne and yelling at me that would be great
I'm impressed by our guts and wonder if there's some sort of beef between the two of them
Surely working in a place like this could cause some stress and tension between people
As we wait [I] noticed a small
Peephole in the door I go to it. Look out to the things they're still looking for a way in the finding no success
[undertaken] sense or somehow see me through the door but flip them the bird yeah, I'll do that
I'll be bad littlefinger defense. [I] can't help myself
Hold my middle finger up [21] and smiled finally I get a blast of hype its
Sound response you'll be reprimanded for speaking to be in such a way are still says that amy reprimand me
All you want I'd like to survive this first cover your ears are still shouts walking the wave towards the far end of the room
Stay put until you hear back from me. Thank you. [amy] says with fire [in] [her] voice
She then turns to me and says better do what the man says [yeah], [I'm] not going to question. I'm Gonna cover my ears
[I] clap my hands of the [mayor's] just in time to protect my hearing from the deafening blast
[I'm] still bleeding in the sudden movements cover
My ears makes me feel busy
Dennis clumsily covers one of these years with and one with his bandaged arm when I see the shape is Gonna get myself in check
Compared to Dennis [on] it took top
Shape [I] did that I took the shot that took off hand
Need to make all that means something more bursts of allowed explosive noise start to [bring] out looking through the people again
I see the core one of the beasts
explode
Advantages in a puff of smoke and clear liquid
Looking to my left I see Barksdale into shooting stance at the far
End of the room is firing through a small slit in the wall. He's using some high-powered weapon the likes of which. I've never seen
I see a slight movement of the gun kicks accompanied by Flickr of white life immediately another Monsters down
Its tentacles flailing around aimlessly is most of its core is torn through. I instantly feel gratitude immense satisfaction in knowing
They're being picked off such a way. I think we need to sit down and rest
Just one little bit of a breather
[I] slide down to get the door [and] simply wait listening to the occasional Pattern of what I can assume
Is there blood on the wall? [I] don't know how much time passes. Maybe five seconds
Maybe five minutes
And I don't care feels nice to lay down even with the sensation of blood rushing for my hurt shoulder
When the firing is over, I barely even notice it
Soon after Barksdale walks back over to our side of the room
They're all gone barksdale says and I have really sealed the hangar doors. How do you kill them like that?
I asked classified weapons that quite frankly you have no business being near amy gets to feed returns to the panel on the wall
Thanks, how badly of the civilians heard Barksdale ask one is in very bad shape
[he's] lost a hand a lot of blood the other is not too bad I see laceration on the back, and that's about it
[ok] [a] lot [of] strickland getting that kid strickland survived [a] [me] [ask] sound hopeful yes until you and your friends showed up
[I] thought we were the only ones hang tight
She's on her way with that said he retreats way to the back of the room as if you can't stand to be around us
Any approaches me and looks me over you're in good hands [trickling] will be able to fix you up is she a doctor something
sort of she's also cites
Physicist [but] oddly enough she spent time as a trauma nurse in the army
Strickland a friend of yours yeah
We've known each other for a while
[the] only women receive overachieving then you must be glad [strickland] survive focus on the good not the negative
[I] am [we] usually have lunch together and she's helped me out with a few tight spots my career
[within] a few seconds the door behind us open and woman appears back further in the chamber
She entered the room with what looks like a small suitcase
She's dressed in a very basic way and drab military get up complete with a holstered Sidearm. My name is Connie, Strickland
She says I can't you guys are pretty well, but it's gonna hurt
She looks closely [done] is looking them over with precise care and attention. You're not in the best shape
He [responded] [to] grant hears that can fix you up, but only temporarily you need intensive careful with for that arm first things first though
Circling for the liquid [over] [his] named arm and start stitching
She then wraps his arm with three entire schools of God's blood shows through right away
That's the best [I] can do for now. She tells them giving them a synthetic proud [I] could care less
Dennis mothers of a Cripple do whatever you wanted though it Matters, Strickland
Then looked at me sit [down] and let's see if we can [give] your shirt off
She says I sit down slowly and started unbuttoning my shirt
You have to help me sleep it off my shoulder, [but] we manage. How bad is it I asked
Bad it's almost like a bird, but I've seen much worse your [friends] here for example
I might as well. Talk to strickland if only to distract the pain
You're a scientist, [too]
[chicken] roll [their] eyes [and] she gathers up a needle and thread [I] was always into fringe science
[I] started in labs with the eccentric [Direction] scientists were being funded by the us to work on Combining Dna types
I sort of became obsessed with perfecting human Physiology walls trauma nurse in the army. You are a mad scientist man
I get that a lot, but no not compared to the stuff. We do here
I don't even want to know
Frankly I've learned enough you sound like my mother strickland says she wants to make sure I'm safe and cared for
She knows my job is sort of dangerous, but of course [I] can tell her any details
So she just worries any other family I [ask] [no] she says she works on me. [I'm] a workaholic [no] husband
No kids always been my job until about a month ago, and [I] loved it. What happened a month ago
That's when the teams were [stumbledupon] on to what they thought was a big discovery
Maybe says answering for strickland [yeah], strickland said that big discovery [result] [of] 20-hour workdays
[I've] been sleeping in my office for about a week now
When you guys ran in here, [I] was horrified those barrels outside
I'm not sure if you saw them, but if you shot them [it] could have been bad
Why I asked
The Gray ones are filled with an experimental fuel [that's] highly flammable [the] yellow ones contain liquid nitrogen
Watch [just] laying around
This area is the safest in the building the most secure
What used to be anyway, and take this she says handing before builds painkillers
They won't work immediately
But the [doll] the worst what you're feeling are these the best [idea] what they make me dizzy or out of sorts of something
All again responses and annoyed and determined to look
I'm Gonna hold off
because
if Dennis
Made it this far in so much pain
I can take a little more. [I'll] hold off. [I'm] gonna hold off
[I] don't [need] it that bad really [I] think I don't wanna get lightheaded in case we have to move fast [I] can handle it
Your call strickland says she starts working on me
She slashes the wounded some sort of liquids things like crazy, and [I] gasped the couch
How we all out by war despite my interdimensional food
Yeah, that's not [a] [complaint] with Dennis ready to stab me yet. I'm find his I win
She dabbed at my [eyes] swollen from where markets kicked me
I grit my teeth in pain and try to catch my breath
When it comes out of it a penis and tries to speaking strictly because words are slurred
White light from the ground [Dennis's] you think that caused the power outage [think] that brought monsters out
Could be strickland says your crew is far enough away from the facility at least we [talked] you [were]
Then it's chuckles in a way that makes them sound menacing nope wrong
You thought wrong
So you and Barksdale is the only survivors it seems that way [those] that didn't disappear that there were killed by those things
[circling] says nodding to the secured or
How many were killed?
[I'm] guessing 30 yourself. [I'm] not sure how many were scheduled to come in today?
[I'm] glad to see you where were you when it happened, amy asks
I was in the micro lab on level two striking replies [Parkin] [O'brien] were in there with me and they just disappeared
It looks like they were being stretched distorted and then there was a ball of white light and they were gone
The ball of light just annihilated everything it touched
Would leave a perfectly round hole I [asked] a light bulb turning in my head. We saw some of those up the logging site
Yeah, and I [chavala] white [to] that was probably the same phenomenon
Amy looks at the ground like a child [that's] afraid ask an adult for something finally she asks where did they go?
We don't know strictly says it could be an infinite number of different dimensions or even some dimensions that merge and [mix] together
[it] could also be a place that exists between dimensions are still called Avoid
I'd call it Dead
No, we keep tabs on the heart rate blood pressure and breathing of all the rats and human test subjects
Wherever they go for that time. They're still very much alive
[I] went through the rest of strickland stitching past
Feeling the tug my skin thankfully no more [flowing] blood trickling finally says you're good to go. She looks over Dennis one more time
[he] doesn't so much faster when you recheck your work
She's already having to remove the gods on his wrist as it soaked through with blood the wound looks like it's starting to clock
So that's good at least I stare at the floor strictly does what you can we make it I asked. [I'm] not a doctor
Not really, but based on the bit. I know [I've] fades about 5050 right now
So we have you and [Barksdale] been able to contain all those creatures a mask strickland appear shocked clearly not the reaction amy was expecting
Contain are you nuts. You not know what's happening?
Amy's eyes widen fearful confusion. What [do] you mean?
What's happening other than the initial experiment failure the anomalies are becoming more numerous and further from the source?
[Michael] says the casual humor and voice is gone
further from the source are they
Everywhere now from the location of the original experiment the experiment called the first doorway to open, but it set off a chain reaction
They're gaining momentum along g-O-D six emanating from the facility
If these pockets of exotic matter negative energy that are letting those things in what the hell does that mean?
It means any chosen those doorways and monsters are starting to appear all over the facility maybe even the surface
Not yet, luckily the doorways will start appearing on the surface, and it won't stop there
The anomaly's reach could extend infinitely as far as we know those entities will appear on the surface in other states other countries
Holy shit
I think you mean the world is going to be overrun the horror of the past Few years that may be ready to believe anything
But this is almost too much
unfortunately, yes
My God in the systemic way is there anything that we could do there is a last resort?
[circle] [assess] her eyes guarding over barksdale to back of the room
[there's] an emergency fail-safes which what he says I never heard of that where you weren't cleared for him
And that's which is a way to stop this
Yes, [strickland] feeling uneasy with conversation
What does this switch do?
The switches are eraser it destroys the entire
Facility and terminates any systems are experiments that are being conducted
[it's] also an emergency shutdown for interdimensional travel
It puts an event horizon around the facility
What the hell is that a black hole? It's the perimeter of a black hole [the] boundary inside which nothing can escape not even light
But there's two problems with [hitting] the switch
So the first problem is we'd all be killed sucked into a black hole before we have time to evacuate the second reason
Is that Barksdale won't allow it what why not he wants [to] allow those things to plug the flood the surface
thousands Millions will die
Strickland put your hand up silencing amy they both peer over to the far side of the room or Barksdale has factor
[I] know. I know he says he doesn't care
He says he'll be happy to be rid of the oversight so we can continue his work
the
Oversight Amy almost screams regaining control of her voice was stricken gives her another look at warning you mean our government
[I] [asked] he's aware this could disrupt even topple our government, and he doesn't care
Are still is well? He's off the range now
It's gone rogue, and he's armed [this] comment makes me look towards the [handgun]. [I] brought in with me
[I] nearly forgotten in the last few moments
[are] still has his back turned [their] taking my hand and slide behind me?
Just in time too as Barksdale walks over from back the radar side of the chamber
He gives Strickland suspicious
Look before speaking door
Of the two civilians going to survive he asks that is chuckles at this number revealed to see the designs are open
He gives the [lazies] [thumbs-up] one is stitched up and good to go to the other here's a bad shape he needs immediate medical attention
Understood Marshall says Amy is quite nice to see that you survived are there any others?
The loose way this asshole is talking to us getting under my skin
[and] guy named marcus that works on the first level from [mighty]. That's all I know for sure
Marcus [path] Scott where is he we're not sure he was separated from us. Oh [large-scale] replies clearly taken aback by Mr.
Reply that's unfortunate
Are still seems to think about something that looks directly at me [you're] with the logging crew. Are you remind me?
How did you get in here again? We were searching for our crew
Ah makes sense the clothes for the entrance share tied to a primary source are still says we lost primary power before the experiment failed
[close] [to] ask
Yes, strickland says the shed you entered is usually not visible to the naked eye depending on the power sources that were damaged are still
Continues it could have also shut down the locking systems before backup script in
Everything is starting to make sense down from the very start it seemed, [too]
Peculiar that we so easily been able to walk into a place like this
What caused the experiment fail the crew [have] one of our main power lines?
We aren't sure exactly how but we know that's what did it trying to blame all this on be the timing was unfortunate
Where's the rest of our crew?
[so]
Your crew Frank and Joe they're gone gone
Gone where they were annihilated by antimatter pockets created during the failure a bright ball of light destroy them
In the aftermath all you'd see would be a round hole in the ground are still says it's like you sharing yesterday's sports scores
And let my face crumble into my hands at [suspecting] this
All this time and they were already dead
Behind me Dennis lets out the beginning to sob
in
[game] he mutters over and over so amy [asked]. What do we do now?
Now it's time to continue our work are still says calmly turning way to the instruments near the wall. You're insane
That is very clearly you want to keep your little toy to yourself
I say my teeth clenched, and you're willing to unleash those monster on the wall on the world to do it
Indeed barksdale says I want to continue my work other researchers will eventually discover what we have sure but I wanted to be me
This is my laboratory these are my experiments the work I've led here will earn me my place in history
and quite frankly
I don't need to explain it to you up on the surface [will] struggle to defend themselves since they won't know what they're dealing with
[I] have the necessary weapons
After a few months who knows maybe I'll decide the world is ready for me to help them and we'll go from there
Strickland steps up directly beside me and whispers in my ear
[I] wouldn't push she says is usually very logical, but this whole thing has pushed [him] somewhere else. He's well off
He turns his back to us if he says he's walking to the far side of the chamber like were some kind of distraction
Amy takes this opportunity to whisper to us we need to hit that switch
It's the only option
What he's saying is Murder treason
Genocide she looks over to strickland for support trailing off
But strickland looks to the ground clearly torn [she] won't look anyone in the eye and makes an effort not to look at Barksdale
He seems distracted with whatever instrument. You studying on the far side of the river at this moment
I realized my body feels like a bomb went off inside it. Maybe those painkillers wouldn't have been so bad
Strickland finally Whispers response even if we decide that we want to hit that switch
Barksdale will allow us you can figure something out, right?
Maybe you guys can make a break [four] [circles] person. Where's the switch located?
There's an elevator around the hangar take it to the basement the switches at the long end of a long tunnel you
At Strickland never finishes two things happened at once she speaks her mouth stopping in mid-sentence
First allowed booming noise rings out, and then the top of her head seems to explode
Amy screams out and surprise [adenosine]. I jump back and shot at Strickland's body collapses, but he made inside me
Behind her falling body are still is holding his experimental rifle, and now he's pointing it at us
Holy shocking the music is way too [confident]
Like God, oh God is good
A wonder if Barksdale is even crazier than marcus. He just shot a woman who worked for him to keep her quiet
Surely he won't have an issue with killing me now barksdale yells. No far whispering. It's no secret
You three will stay in here and get away from that door if anyone whispers one more time
I'll blow your heads off my mind is racing to figure out a way to get through the security door and into the hangar
Beyond that of course business [failsafe] switch
And solving Barksdale might not be the best idea make a distraction
Maybe I try my best to be a good actress that wobbled my experiments. I stop-start forward again, and then [wobbled] some more
Amy is apparently catching on because [you've] got my side in a second she looks over at [Barksdale]
He's lost a lot of blood let me check his wounds real quick
After he [appeared] to talk to me like that. He's been through a lot. He's clearly delusional
[then] it seems to not know quite know what's going on
But luckily our [steelers] and paying attention to them you can check him back here
You have 30 seconds to get away from that door or I will
[I] stretch out my acting skills and actually stumbled with me
[I] make a show of trying to get to my feet and still stand still for a moment
I'm okay. I'm okay. [I] think I as quickly as I can raise my gun and fire. [I] don't even take Aim
I just fire and Barksdale general Direction are still takes off running at my shop Mrs.
Why'd you run for cover to the back of the room?
[that's] all we need any fires a shot to keep them undercover as we head for the door
And he pushes a button and the door swings open
Are still will be honest in a second so we dashed out of the hangar ready to defend ourselves?
[I] can't believe it
Just killed strickland there must be something going on that is driving people insane because Marcus and barksdale seem to be very
off-color
Like [it] seems like [something] is very wrong
All three of us run as fast as we can get through the role of barrels right away
Though are still gunfire separates us here shot
Hit nearby is that dive down and realize that not a dentist or amy's with me
Here any cry out from somewhere else in the barrel during around the barrel close to me
[I] can see Dennis is [growing] slowly on the floor two rows away from me. [he] [moves] so slowly
I can't imagine how he's finding the strength to even do that
Stop this nonsense
[I've] got a good mind to shoot the fuel and kill all of you
It's then that I realized that not getting away from him these barrels. Maybe our death sentence
Well, I mean, there's like either a selfish thing or not selfish thing, but I'm [gonna] tell them to get away
I'm trying to be good here before I can do anything a shot comes from the isolation chamber
[it's] immediately followed by a pinging sound in a massive wall of heat
[I] feel the heat before I feel the force of the explosion occurs several roles ahead of me
And I can still feel the physical push of it
here Dennis screen [and] the clanging of Metal
That's [one] another barrel [explode] and then another and [I] realized I could run back and help or try to get myself clear
I gotta help. [I] might not have enough time to [do] either before the next round of eruptions. What the hell should [I] do?
[I've] got to help them [I've] gotta help them I cannot help them my instinct to help overcome my instinct to survive
[if] I don't help them now the exploding barrels will leave [Dennis], and [maybe] as good as dead
I [turn] [and] start heading their way, but I'm not quick enough
Another barrel blows up between us and throws me back across the hangar floor
My face and [arm] screen with the unimaginable pain of the [burden] [has] [been] lifted from the ground and touch forward by the explosion
[I] slowly muscle myself up off the ground and try to regain my footing my entire body feel sword begging me to just stop
When [I] look back for [Dennis], [and] maybe [two] seam is not promising [either] [of] them seems to be able to move on their own
Sentences lying flat on its face on moving amy is about 20 feet away from them
She's wailing in pain and clutching your legs behind them I can see barksdale looking for another shot to the fire and evaporated liquid nitrogen
I fire off a single shot just to get them to duck behind Barrel
[back] and find anything see the fire nearing the fuel barrels
[I] can maybe keep barksdale pinned down long enough to pick them up
One by one and help them walk to the elevators of more barrels could blow at any moment
Not only have time to save one of them. Oh
No
Oh, no, I have to pick
[Dennis's]
I'm not even looking at this from like I know Dennis
I know amy standpoint like Dennis is the one who is hurting more? I don't even
God [damn] [it] fuck
You chose to help Dennis first [take] a deep breath and Sprint back out and be [opening] fire and heat right away
I started taking blind shots at Barksdale
He fires back only once in the shot goes off and growing flames around me
I take one more shot, and then reached down for Dennis is basically Dead weight at this point. He's almost, too
Heavy for me my wounded shoulder screams in pain as [I] get him to his feet
I dragged back [narrowly] avoiding the fire and yes, I try shooting a bar sale
But keep trying to keep the gun in the gun while carrying down [its] proved to be too much
Or she'll get single shot off as we round the corner to where the elevator weights, I tennis down and he's still unresponsive
For instance when I real around and head back to get amy only make it a single step before [I] see here
I open-mouth might not call to her an explosion right beside her cuts me off
[she] [shoved] hard to the left from the force of the explosion. I've run to help the barksdale is firing me again
[I] give [a] me one last regretful. Look and then rush back to the elevator and [Dennis] my nerves are drenched in Fear and adrenaline
But every [chapter] press the call button on the elevator. It feels like I'm watching someone else do it
As Dennis, and I step inside the motors on the elevator squeal like dying dogs
It's an old service elevator made of wood and metal like something from a coal mine
At the elevator slides down the light from the flames giveaway to complete blackness
And now it's just me and Dennis once again good. God
The fuck is happening man. This is fucking ridiculous
This is fucking insane
There's gotta be something with this event that is driving people mad. I lose track of how long the elevator descends
It's hard to tell you the lack of lighting
But it must go down another 500 feet underground
The elevator comes to a stop [at] the shuttering
clang and [wastes]
No time exiting the tunnel stretches out with Sparse white all lighting the way
Most of the walls made some raw [hers] and [rocked] their boards and concrete [slab] [Daenerys] used to reinforce the tunnel
[is] your warning sign posted on the wall?
[I] want to read it
But there's not much time [I] [gotta-I] Gotta read the notice [I] mean what what's really going to keep me up?
I mean he's 5-under feet up to read at least warning
Authorized personnel only Beyond this point trespassers will be prosecuted to the full extent of the law
Absolutely, no exceptions well glad to get out that way now that [everyone] [is] dead after only a few steps the pain in my body
Intensifies, how stupid would like to turn down those painkillers?
I mean, it would have made me slow
I look up and when [I] see that the tunnel ceiling [is] less than six inches over my head claustrophobia freezes for a moment
The feeling is not high and there's barely enough room for [Dennis] to me to walk Side-By-side
His eyes are half closed and he looks on the verge of passing out again. It's okay
I tell we're almost done a little further ok he shakes his head and says. I'm sorry Roger
But I don't think I can go into for further. I lower into the floor as easily as I can and let him rest
I'll be back at home helping it's true. This [one] should be down here somewhere
[I] give [Dennis] one last look and then start down the tunnel [and] enemy
I look up and when [I] see that the tunnel ceiling is less than six inches over my head
Claustrophobia freezes me for a moment still much better than facing the monsters above me [where] things repeated again
I wonder been walking through the darkness where they came from [it] the portal still
Open [I] keep walking into the darkness and within five minutes the glow of the red light from the elevator is diminished
Almost completely dark hold the gun in one hand and reach out to touch the wall with my other
Feeling the gun in my palm anchors meet a reality to sanity
[I'm] not in some boundless [of] business
But still in the real world for a little while longer and at least
I'd recognize that [are] marching to my end as much as I wish I worked
It's not surprising from the moment that I saw those creatures could do to time and space
At least a part of me knew the death was inevitable
Before I have time to wonder what will happen [I] see light ahead
[there's] nothing more than a speck of blue light in the darkness of the tunnel. It's like a lighthouse on a stormy sea
Ice log forward my [I] straining to focus on. What little light-headed from somewhere ahead. I start to hear something
That sounds like water is trickling like slightly like a leaky faucet
Behind that there's something that sounds like wind a light breeze an open field and voice
Anywhere else that sounds would have been pleasant appeared in the blackness of the tunnel. They are menacing. Well, that's not to break character
I keep shouting of the darkness through this whole story hello
[Hellooo] my voice doesn't [feel] like it shouldn't a small space this weirds me out even more than the lack of
Response [I] cock my head trying to concentrate and then I realized that I can see the Tunnel walls now
This is odd [as] [I] wasn't able to see them a few seconds ago
[this] [is] different from the blue light at the end of the Tunnel
is then that [I] see the slight shimmering in the air looks like a fog a mirror steamed over after a shower and it's
Dancing in the air like some abstract [firefly]
Not menacing like the creatures for that threat is no
It's a peaceful
Serene [I've] watches with shimmer branches out becomes two then three then four
a snake out in different directions tracing the Tunnel long
But these shimmers with doors to another dimension that strickland was talking about
Suddenly [I'm] surrounded by light above and below me and I realized there's no avoiding it
The question is how am I going to go through all right dive headfirst [let] me stick my head through and feel a tingling sensation
Almost pleasant every time slowly my [hand] stretching out to one of those shimmers what I can only assume some kind of light
They're hypnotizing so much so that they don't [realize] [that] the Tunnel walls are vanishing
I feel something like wind and a brief electrical pulse [passed] through me at the lights
Take me there has been a very gentle pushing sensation
And I somehow know that I'm being expelled [I] passed through something. Maybe the lights
Maybe the Tunnel wall, I don't know the shimmering lights fade a bit still dancing in the air, but no longer large and branching out
And as my eyes adjust [I] see right away that I'm no longer standing in that dark Tunnel far beneath the hangar
[I] have no idea where I have just
somewhere else
And I'm terrified
So are these like the lights that took whoa?
whoa
Are these like the lights that took everyone else that I just get taken?
The ground I land on looks like hot coals
[they're] dipped in many clips breaking the landscape ahead of me as a wash of orange and blue overhead [and] the sky that makes no
sense
It's both beautiful and terrifying it once
A scattering of stars [and] overhead and they all seem to be breathing and pulsing with the gentle energy. It's alive
[I] can't tell if there are clouds in the sky because everything about it from the colors to the trembling Horizon line
Seems to be able to finish everything is Knitted together living
[I] stare a moment longer [can] swear I feel the skies reading far off to my right
I think what looks to be a clip of fire small get right with no source of fuel
[it] looks as if the ground itself is creating the flaming several more of these flames got the landscape further out
The Air is thick and muggy then I realized something horrible
I don't know what I'm breathing he resembles air it all in a place like this one of the impossible beauty
But also very straightforward my mind doesn't know what to do a wave of nausea consider mean
I think I may be sick, not sure it would be better to fight it or give in
The white light that brought me here is nowhere to be found
If anyone else even here is there any way to escape?
Well better continue my yelling
[take] a deep breath, whatever other worlds gas filling this place belt out as loud as I can hello know
If everybody here [here] voice in response [its] faint distant. I turned [in] here coming to one of the massive crevices along the ground
Inside of that crack about 10 feet down [a] very pale man lies on a [ledge] these humans, but looks close to death
He's in the center of a very large
Pool of blood in his left leg has been twisted and porn in the natural way that walk to let you [looks] [of] it easily
Help me, please
The man said his eyes are wide although everything about him speaks of the weakness is close to death or sanity or both
Who are you? I'm
Dr. Comma [key] strength to get out of work in the facility
He's the one that disappeared and never came back in the [experiment], please
I want to know more, but it seems cool to feel what looks like its last threat
Just answering my question. [I'd] love to but [I] don't know where the hell. I am how to get back home
The light it's a doorway might take you back
to the facility
Where did it go?
They come come and go
We'll be back now, please help me
[I] desperately want to help, but there's no way I can reach him [ledges] too far away above the pools of fire
[I] don't think I can get to you [know] that's not what [I] meant
He replies his eyes are on the handgun that I almost forget that I'm still holdin I realize what he wanted to shake my head
[I] can't I can't do that, please
Those things they have the others that came here with me. I got dropped along the way
They'll be back. We'll be back and will kill me that
will be quicker and less than
I can't repeat. Please look at my damn leg. I'm dead anyway
[and] the batter refuse them again when [I] hear an all-too-familiar static sound out from another credits behind him
I hear another one of those shrill noise, and then watched one of the creatures material life itself
Out of the neighborhood credit neighboring crevice two more come out of to that [then] [the] third than 5 [1010] [soon]
[I] lose count is what was just a few turns into a [flogging]
And I suddenly understand the man's reasoning a bullet would be a mercy. I checked the gonna see I only have one round left
Can use it on this guy, but [I] may need it for myself later
From beside me the man please again my God he says please
not a decision that I take lightly but
Who knows how long he's been here? [they] said that experiment was like what a month ago
You chose to shoot the man?
[I] look back to the man wins [I] know it's the right thing to do but my finger [resist]
With the roar of disgust I level the gun [to] his head turn my eyes away, and then pull the trigger
Your aim is true
Man [crumbles] lifelessly to the ground and that's when I see the [shimmers] wavering to my right in the direction
[I] originally came from
[I] [look] back to the monsters can see that they have not noticed me
Some of them to get floating of the walls of [the] [crevasse]
There are less than [10] feet separating us the shimmers white light within arm's reach its movements [reminded] me of a fish in the aquarium
I reach out [and] feel [myself] accepted by them again
[I] feel the sensation of wind and wait for the feeling of being pushed out back to the tunnel of this facility
But it doesn't come this time this time
I feel something else feel a tugging sensation that seems to want to drag me in all directions at once
[as] the world goes dark I realize that I'm somewhere else and it is not the darkness of the tunnel
This is the darkness of a total [void] and this story has taken us wild
places
And it's fucking
[there] is darkness around me everywhere
nothing this
I feel nothing under my feet nothing to my [side]. [I] can't punch or said anything at all
You know I don't even know which way is up or down it [is] [still] [I] am all that exists
and as I remain there
I just hear silence [not] even the sound of my heart beat the blackness is so deep that I feel I can't distinguish my
Thoughts and what is real? [I] hear screaming, but [I] can't tell if it's someone else on my mind
screaming to fill this void
And I'm going to cry out because that's what I do
I hear my own shot in my head, but it doesn't seem to travel at me abyss
It bounces in my head endlessly like an echo down along ancient corridor
I assume this is the place that strickland referred to
[place] between dimensions [this] darkness could consume me if it wanted to do
[I] try to [will] myself out of it to have those shimmering lights pick me out, but it isn't happening
At this point my mind starts to hallucinate early staffing it does
Divisions my mind playing tricks on me. [I] can't tell all [I] can do is watch
[I] think the logging site and [Tony's] like still pinned under the dozer
[I] feel a pang of regret, and I left him in such a stream
Actually [bunch] [of] talking to Dennis and looks distraught as [I] tell [them] the Tony is gone
And the scenes rearranges itself an outstanding between Dennis and Marcus's gun
[change] [together] [the] shape of [marks] lies on the ground still hell-bent on revenge even after I let him live
In my mind, I'm sobbing as I shoot opportunities hand trying to convince myself
It was the only way to save him, but he will never forgive me
I tried to let out a scream as Dennis and I [watching] [me] get blown apart by the barrel explosions
But this don't know sound and just when I feel like I can't take anymore of this [she] [believes] [in] the strange world
begging for death
I watch as [I] take his life just before those beasts reach him
All of these things are flooding my mind, and it feels like my brain is vomiting
[get] in the midst of it. All [I] see what's really important
the switch
In my mind's eye I see that glowing like the [tunnels] the one far ahead small and distance
I focus my mind the tunnel the image of that flickering light
with a mental effort so strong
It's nearly [a] physical motion and make myself envision that little light in the tunnel as if it were right there in front of me
With that I feel win again a light breeze that seems to come from everywhere
And then with a relief that I can only imagine feels like death and move forward
Sheba's, holy God I'm rejected from the void and suddenly standing in the Tunnel again
[I] let out a wail of triumph that turns into about of [weeks] the weeping only intensified when [I] see that light up ahead a
Flickering blue light somewhere behind me I hear crackling noise. [I] can only hope they haven't reached Dennis
It's too late to even worry about that after coming this far. [I'm] not about to turn back
[I] feel like [I] can listen to get a better read [them] where they are
Or I can just make a break for it try to listen better than just Sprint
[I] try my best to listen attempting to figure out how far away. They are
But [they] sound carries strangely down here right now that static sounds makes it seem like they're only about 30 yards away
Knowing my time is running out of run as fast as my aching and confused body below now
Headed straight for the blue light as I run actually a different light a white one twittering in my peripheral vision
It's another one of those shimmers that go to other worlds. It seems like they're appearing and disappearing with more frequency now
Strickland was right
These things could reach the surface soon unleashing more monsters
This thought makes me refocus on the blue light the man-made life [the] switch the blue light gets closer
And as it does I can make out a square shape around it this has to be it
The familiar static screen of the monsters is much closer now. [I] have to be quick the grunt work
I [grabbed] the gun tightly regretting my decision to use last bullet on the man in the [otherworld]
looks like all of me using the Sport is
alleged [a] [running] [head] into the darkness my eyes locked on the switch that is soon going to kill not only the
creatures of myself as well
As I [approached] sexy the lever it's covered by glass box that [will] need to break the blue light is directly beneath this
Highlighting a series of tubes and wires that snake into the inner portions of the device in the middle
Is blackness not like a darkly colored part of the machine, but just a hole in reality it looks like some sort of illusion
All the while, I can hear static of the creatures coming up dangerously close now. [I] have no idea how much time I have
Got press forward Smash that glass
[I] draw back [to] stock [it] going to smash through the glass box the houses lever
The glass shattering like music to my ears
I reach out to the level my hand grasping it without warning. I feel immense pain course through my body feels
I fire racing down my back causing me to fall the one need in agony
There's only one of them that I can see it black horrible static noise
It makes I've [already] my gun with no bullets left. I get ready to use it as a club
[I] try to strike the monster gun that's the gun away wrapping it into an [s-shape] then follows up by swinging and appendages that [bee]
Sting of its touch forcing me back against the side of the cavern my [face] striking the wall hard [my] job crunches
And I feel sharp pain and compass my hand and the creatures upon me
Its tentacles melt into me and ice cream and can't help it
I sound like a wild animal [I] can try to keep putting it off
Or I can go for broke and just focus on the lever creatures be damned
[I'm] going to the lever
I put all my strength in my legs
The moment of the monster in front of the Drawers back [into] feel like arms grabbing a pivot backwards
My back strikes the machine sending agony rocketing through my body
I'm so thankful I broke the glass before this moment before the coming violence
[I] stretch out and grab the lever with one last desperate screen that shreds my voice. I jam it down
The Tunnel is suddenly filled with a flash of intense darkness it expands from swallowing the matter around it at first
I'm sure this is the end of I expect the darkness to consume [me] followed by death
Then another shimmer of dancing light appears next to me there are more of those streams of life
Rips in space like the ones that previously sent me to the other
Ungodly world in the void with nothing else to do but die [I] tried to escape into the shimmer
That [stream] [with] light envelops makes the expanding darkness of this which is gone, and I feel a huge push
Oh shit
My own space my body feels stretched collapsing like I'm falling in all directions at once the world goes white and then there are
pinpoints of stars everywhere one of the breezes indirectly by my right
And I see something that looks like a spiral Galaxy
Distorted [its] folds to my right is he an endless stretch of stars and gas clouds forming some galactic architecture?
But Beyond the immeasurable beauty I noticed something
[I'm] seeing the same star patterns over and over there repeating like reflections in an endless mirror for these
Are these different versions of the same galaxies the same realities to my left?
I see a calm blue world and can barely make out trees
Familiar Kentucky freeze that I've been around for the last few weeks
To my right I see a copy an orange world where the trees well, but something is strange
disturbing assume by I'm not sure how much control I have in this unusual place, but if I can direct myself
[it's] worth trying is so weird
Me personally I'm drawn towards the orange one because it's something new
And I was weirdly drawn towards it. I don't know why I try to focus my mind
[I'm] heading towards the orange world not knowing what to expect
[a] breath escapes me for a moment everything is dark and peaceful and nothing hurts
Yeah, I don't even know why like [I] because obviously the blue world is the familiar world that [I] came from but this orange world
is like
What's in there?
Why does it exist?
With breath back inside my body I [gasps] [been] opened my eyes. [I'm] back
back at the logging site
How I'm not sure that the shimmers react with the explosion of the switch some of [their] accident
[I] have no idea. I said up right away and become instantly dizzy Dennis
[I] say [I] have no reason to think that he survived whatever happened in the Tunnel
[but] there's some sort of certainty that gets me to my feet
I wonder if I'm somehow back in time before we found facility
But what happens next makes me realize that can't be true [and] start walking forward [I] feel a tremor in the ground that
Someone off in the distance I hear a metallic groan the buried facility is being ripped apart underground
But the activation of the switch there's no way Barksdale and [market] survived
Good riddance. [I] stumbled a bit and what [I] do [I] see the body in the forest floor
Dennis
How is he here [if] you get caught in those shivers as well? [I] decided [on] [Karen] Scramble over to Dennis
Can you hear me? Yeah? He says the slightest twitch behind his eyes for the moment. That's good enough for me
To my left through a tangle of partially destroyed trees and woodland a pillar of smoke begins to rise into the air
We've made it out of the facility alive at that. I suppose the most important thing, but something feels off in a way
I [can't] explain [its] been as I look up and notice this guy that it starts the second
There's something different about it something not right that sky does not belong here [this] guy's oranges and blues
Stars pulse in and out as if a life [the] colors of the sky seemed to breathe
and if they're trying to inhale the tops of the spruce trees [I] see those colors all knitted together and living my stomach Rules and
arises up in my throat
the hell and gone
but there and
What why?
oh
Oh, no
Oh, Dal. [oh], no
Oh my God, [the] good what that's the end?
[ok] let's talk about this tough it out was logical because you don't the painkillers clouding your judgment?
Jennifer has been with me the whole time. [I] can't leave him behind
And also I didn't know that I didn't know for a certainty that it would kill one of the other I don't know
And [I] [and] Thirty percent of people
Killed [the] man or not many people and then very very few people went to the orange world
And I don't know what that means the choice between the blue and the orange world, but they're like parallel dimensions
But one exists in the world with that weird on fire hell
Landscape world was the same sky the oranges and blues [that] was the same sky
The Facility was still ripped apart so what does that mean did I have control over the reality of what happened?
Or is this a parallel world where?
Something has been changed. I don't know but that's the end there any sort of oh
oh
Oh, okay. Oh, [no]
What did I do?
[oh]
It was amazing [that] was an amazing story. That was just
Unbelievably amazing story, [I] had the time of my life
[it] was like a book that I couldn't put down it was so good and so weird. That's little confusing
What were the differences were my choices they were so vast?
Oh my God is fucking incredible
Like are there different endings to this. [I] have no idea. I have no idea
How many endings are let me look that up actually I'm [look] that up oh man
I can't [I] can't find anything on an explicit walkthrough
But [I] think this is something that you guys just have to experience for yourself
[there's] a lot of choices that need to be made in this game
and [I] don't know how much of a vast impact it has on the actual ending what the ending fully means with the
Ramifications of what I have done, but I don't know it's something that you guys have to find out for yourself
So if you want to play this and you want to make your own choices
And you want to experience your own story with probably better choices, and I made but my choices were true to me
Try for yourself link in the description, but thank you everybody so much for joining me on this adventure. [this] was a ride
This was a wild ride, and I loved every second of it. So thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you think of this down the comments below because there is so much to process and I'm going to be thinking
About this all day long [would] [be] the way. Thanks again, and as always I will see you
in the next
Bye bye!
*Dank music*